this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by expressvpn stamps calm and
keeps more on that later
let's get into the do the honeydew with
Ryan Sickler
[Music]
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here at the honeydew Studios doing
it at the Santa Monica Music Center I am
Ryan Sickler I'm Ryan Sickler on all
social media Ryan Sickler calm go to the
website sign up for my email list you'll
be the first to know about any updates
regarding myself the shows all that good
stuff and if you haven't yet please go
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
where the video is youtube.com slash our
Sickler also make sure you follow my
facebook fan page as well be getting a
lot of content over there and the
honeydew with you all the patreon I'm
loving it we've already recorded a few
episodes go submit your story if you
think you have a story to tell just give
me some bullet points do not write a
four-page email some of y'all just give
me the bullet points and we'll go
through them we'll definitely get back
to you check your spam folders I've been
responding to some people they're not
getting it check your spam folders and
maybe we'll get into an episode together
the website for the show here the
honeydew podcast.com that's where you
can go get all your merch your hoodies
your night pants I cannot thank you all
enough night pants nation is growing I
love seeing you all out there and as
soon as we get out there and do live
shows and [ __ ] I'm gonna be wearing
night pants we're gonna do a night pants
tour look I just want to say a huge
thank you to the Santa Monica Music
Center here my friend Lana agretti I
record here and if you live in the Los
Angeles area and you want or need
musical instruments or lessons for your
kids or for you this is the spot they're
a family-owned business they've been
around for 50 years
and they're great people so with all the
uncertainty with the virus they've been
offering online classes and if you live
in Ohio your kids or even you can be or
can get lessons from kick-ass local Los
Angeles musicians so go to Santa Monica
music.com use code honeydew and they
will waive the registration fee and give
you one free lesson when you sign up for
a package shout out a lot of agretti all
right now if you're new to the show
or if you're just coming back for more
do y'all what we do here is we highlight
the lowlights I say these are the
stories behind the storytellers and it
is a pleasure to have this storyteller
back on to do y'all four legs
three duis two passports from Channel
One News y'all you know I'm also from
Leatherman Jimmie Josh Adam Meyers do I
always heard about listen to this right
I want you I love Gallagher's like bed
music but I just want to hear you going
unto do y'all like just throw that you
know thank you you're welcome I
appreciate you being here
very well I actually showed up here for
the piccolo lessons I have a I love it
this is you know it's we've worked so
many times on a different podcast
whether it was the crap fees honey do
you come in on the 500 you coming on the
pre 500 show that never the pre-plan 3
pre pre so I always I've just been
looking forward to this for the last few
days so me too dude
and look how far we've come to again a
huge shout out to everybody at your
mom's house to stop I mean it started
this podcast in my kitchen because we
weren't we didn't have the video up yet
and yeah and I did not want to let
people down and have a lapse and be like
oh you know I'll do it March I wanted to
go right from the end of the crab feast
at that Christmas episode into the do
and here we are in our own studio I mean
it's it's like I said it before off air
like you this is beautiful like you
should be so proud of this this studio I
mean I mean just just wanna be like
talking in the middle and suddenly this
thing is good
you just wish I'd ignore let's keep
going keep going
canvas just we got a team here
just ignore them just keep telling her
story the audio still in port but yeah
we were originally we were gonna work
together and then you got five minutes
podcast so please plug promote anything
you would like ah so Josh Adam Meyers on
all social media I have a podcast on
Spotify called the five hundred with
Josh Anna Meyers where I'm going through
Rolling Stone magazine's list of the 500
greatest albums with like huge comics
huge rock stars actors just people of
like of like influence and it's great
because we're just it's an album week
and we use the album is kind of like a
road map to interview them you did BB BB
King which was still one of my favorite
episodes and you're on deck for any
other Blues and I might just call you
out all right I might just call you out
me like hey man How well do you know
about the rythmics thank you you know
the rhythmic s-- cuz I need somebody
analytics is my great-aunt but you can
it's like all right Andy chill out we're
at we're at my cousin's christening
shut the [ __ ] up and where you can find
it at the 500 podcast.com and the 500
podcasts on all social media check it
out I love making it so I'm very excited
to have you back for just a lot of
reasons this virus to has been so stupid
it's nice to have some human contact and
and sit across from you but the if you
haven't listened to to Josh's crappy
episodes they're [ __ ] legendary you
got to go listen to those and then his
first episode here where we actually did
your episode was and a bit different
which I love because it was it was
basically why you are the way yeah her
and how things got to where there are so
I want to go back to and listen to that
as well but I want to go back and
embrace the Jimmy Josh did I know
because I asked you to come up with some
story
you're like I got them so you know do
what you do let's start with what I'll
say it I'll say I'll say it so it all it
all starts around ninth grade because in
ninth grade was when and I've talked
about this on the piece but I had these
friends when people had never heard I
had this group of friends that I used to
hang out with my buddy Greg my buddy
Seidenberg aka dead cat from de shekels
and this guy Kenny and they were the
guys that kind of like introduced me
into drinking right started with like so
nothing prior to that you hadn't tried
really anything you know I stole I stole
one of my mom's cigarettes those extra
long mission friend delight and I cried
it but I wasn't like no cuz I wasn't
I just never like thought about it it
wasn't like drugs and stuff kind of like
a drinking kind of started when I went
people that I thought were cool we're
doing it do you know II mean in like
Greg Seidenberg and Kenny were older
than me like Greg and Seidenberg were
like two years two grades above me so
when I was in tenth they were in twelfth
yeah and then I'm in Kenny I think was
like 21 he just worked with Seidenberg
at a giant and but he was like he was
like the guy that used to get us all the
booze so we start drinking like going
over to like Greg's house and and you
know it's just like the normal [ __ ] like
you have a shot and then you know maybe
do like five more shots after you have
no control over like how you drinking we
just [ __ ] threw them back and then we
go back then also - and I don't I don't
mean never up but as a kid you don't
realize there is an option to have two
beers and feel you know what I mean
right
exactly so I'm saying you when you're
that age drinking is to get [ __ ] up
yeah it's not like drinking responsibly
or who's gonna have a couple beers get a
nice little buzz and you know well let
it wear off and go home it's like I want
to piss my pants and Judis when when we
realize how deep my mom and dad's liquor
cabinet was
like dude we went [ __ ] bananas like
cuz it was right there here's a
television it's right there we could see
it and Greg would be like yo man you
know we should why don't we just have
some of that rum so I mean we would just
whittle down these bottles a night and
then just wait till night commercial we
would but like my parents would go to
bed and then we grab like the rum and we
pull some shots out we'd mark it where
it was and then we fill that up with
water to the point where I remember we
had done that so much that I think it
was like maybe like a year after we
started drinking like my mom just like
it around the holidays and me and Greg
are like hanging out in my bedroom and
my mom just goes what Josh she's like I
tried to make rum cake and it was all
water and we're just like I don't play
it off like run room turn girl so so so
we stopped drinking at at my house and
we would just go to Greg's and Greg was
also this guy that loved [ __ ] with
people do you know what I mean I got
called him the instigator because that
was all he did so Greg and I would just
like non-stop [ __ ] with scene Berg dead
cat to the point where we get drunk like
dead cat was like into Led Zeppelin like
he was a huge Led Zeppelin fan and he
would get drunk and just like find these
empty coke bottles and start like
playing like fake drums like using the
coke bottles and and Greg came up with
the idea is like when he does that okay
dude we used to I mean he started he
started doing it and we would be like
buckets we'd be like buckets but on the
bottles we'd be like me and Greg would
go dude holy [ __ ] man like you're good
and like dude I love dead cat you know
he was he was just alive he's alive he
even he ignores everything about me any
messages
I send him like he does not want
anything to do with me and it's a dead
the big cat I'm in it yeah because we
[ __ ] with him so much man like we but
it was like that one we just he just had
about hopper you though yeah you got
what he cuz what dude this was this is
the one that like really really did it
right was so he would start he'd get
drunk he start playing with the coke
bottles and we would be like we've acted
you're really good right oh he was
though right you're not [ __ ] no he was
Tara hard you know beat like you'd be
like it's misty mountaintop like just
lovely what was he into shekels he was a
rapper but he was like the old dirty
bastard into shekels like he he couldn't
rap but he got better as time went on
like there was like IDE like a ghost
rode a little bit I'm not gonna lie but
yeah he was just he was just he was the
homie man and I love Mike to death to
this day even if he doesn't want
anything to do with me but so we started
[ __ ] with them with the with the
bottles and then like Mike started going
out and like spending money on like drum
related things like he got like a drum
pad and some sticks and he started
carrying the sticks around and we're
like what the [ __ ] is this guy doing
like he's he's terrible
and then me and Greg Aryan sticks he's
30 I mean he's dude he is he's John
Bonham in his head like he really thinks
he's that good and then we come up with
this idea because I'm gonna ban with my
buddy Tasos were like let's bring Mike
over to Tasos his place and have him sit
at the real kit and like have Tasos like
feed him some [ __ ] and so we bring
Mike into Tasos basement we're all there
and like Mike's all excited he's got a
stick sticky I brought my own sticks and
I was like dude go ahead dude let's see
what you can do he sits down
I mean garbage like do dance-punk and
tosses goes whoa are you telling me you
never played before
and I mean he just like starts freaking
out to the point where like he's going
like to Guitar Center to try to buy
drums and me and Greg are like dude we
got to break it to this
right like we have to so one of those
nights were around Kenny's house and
we're all drinking he's got a Tommy
Leary go I've been working on my flips
play twist and shout so he so we decided
to break we decided to break it to him
right like we're like we're like I did
let so we'll get him drunk and then
we'll tell him and so we have him over
and we're drinking we're doing shots and
then Mike's like so yeah I think I'm
going to see that drumset tomorrow and
Greg's just like hey man like we got
something to tell you buddies again what
is it and I'm just like I remember I
turned around I'm like I can't be a part
of this this is the worst thing I've
ever lucky that naive yeah he thought he
was good I mean dude I remember one time
like I wanted to go out to eat at like
in this area of where this Outback
Steakhouse was but he didn't want to eat
there so I was like dude they just
opened up his new place called hot fries
he was like hot fries
you mean like the those little like
cheeto things I'm like dude it's all hot
fries and so then we drove over there he
said where's hot fries I'm like I know
but not McDonald's he was like [ __ ] you
and he was just that dude you know that
you could [ __ ] with so we break it to
him he starts weeping nah it was bad he
cried it was bad it was bad I think I
started crying too because I am so
empathetic sorrow tears but that was
just like cried a lot Mike cried a lot I
think I got my crying from seeing how
open and in touch he was with his own
emotions dude like you know I cry live I
cried on the way here listening to the
Beatles listening a good night from from
the
but it was but basically like Gregg was
that dude and and I know Gregg is gonna
listen to this and be like no you were
that dude but no [ __ ] he's the
instigator like I mean Greg used to do
so much fucked-up [ __ ] to me like I
remember when like it started with like
you fall asleep and they start writing
on your face and then Greg advanced to
like gluing my socks to my feet yeah he
was like I fall asleep move you'd be
passed out and he just lifts up your
sock and take like some Elmer's eggs
Harry is [ __ ] yet II just am dude you
could not you could not get drunk with
him he would [ __ ] with you every time
the worst one that he ever did was hold
on so what happened after he started
crying about the drums it just that was
a wrap on it he didn't believe in
himself enough like will [ __ ] you all
know it was a wrap on the drums it was I
never saw him play coke bottles ever
again that was that was last time he
played the coke bottles but you know we
were such a tight group you know and I
mean this like even though if we [ __ ]
with him like there was so much love
there man like I love that guy but he
would he would just you know do what we
all did when Greg [ __ ] with us or if I
[ __ ] with you or whoever [ __ ] it we
just we'd chock it up and go I you know
I think he spent some time away from us
a little bit but not like disowned us it
wasn't until later where all that [ __ ]
piled up and then he was like he got
into a relationship and he was like I'm
[ __ ] out and then he broke up with
his wife and then came back to us and we
were like you're back and then he got
with a new girl again but but Greg Greg
would just you know he would [ __ ]
never one time I got drunk and I fell
asleep and I must have fallen asleep
like this like curled up on the couch
and when I woke up I was like oh [ __ ]
what time is in there like dude it's
3:30 in the morning and I'm [ __ ] I gotta
get home my parents are gonna be pissed
and I go to the bathroom and they turn
the lights on and look in the mirror he
put like red lipstick like on my face
like I was David Bowie
the whole thing dude I remember I had I
was like walking home pistou and a cop
sees me and a cop like oh [ __ ]
suffragette City but Greg put it
basically just saying is that I I did as
much evil [ __ ] you know to people as
Greg did to but this is the one that is
like I think one of our one of our best
and funniest ones which was so I'm in
ninth grade Greg's in eleventh right and
imma you know I'm not like popular in
the school yet but I'm just like the
funny guy I had such bad a DD and my
parents you know because of my
hyperactivity were giving me like I
remember getting riddle you at age 88
athd
ADHD ADHD b-but it was but it was
because like I was so hyperactive as a
kid like in kindergarten he was taking
ritalin and then I remember and by the
time I got to to middle school in high
school I would take an adderall in the
morning and then I'd have to come back
at lunch and take another adderall what
the nurse would give it he had to dance
in my medicine they were bras to do and
sometimes you can sell those adderall's
back in the day like eight dollars a pop
but but the thing was was was just like
it didn't it didn't work for me in the
sense that it focused me it just made me
more hyper and everybody else just wrote
it off as I guess like no it's working
but I mean I could not pay attention but
I did I was just like at an all-time
high of [ __ ] with people and like
making fun of people in class and
disrupting and there was a guy in my
school named Brian I was called Brian
gladden and he was this pumpkin country
guy that I mean was just short of a few
brain cells like he was just like
everybody like kind of like not [ __ ]
with them but just he was like easy to
like to like get in like you know have
fun with because if you could just
look at him you look at him he go like
gladden and he'd go oh yeah like loud
his [ __ ] the class and he'd stand up
and be like oh gonna get dude like he
was just gone and of course I'm in every
class with him was I say about me
alright but he so he like we were in
class and I think Greg had the idea just
to start teasing about something we were
really obsessed with this this NFL
player for the Redskins I don't if you
remember him named Al Noga remember al
Noga know played for the Vikings he was
just some big Samoan dude like he was
like a heavy version of Jimmy the
Superfly Snuka had the curly hair like
and he was playing for the Redskins at
the time this is probably 1992 so right
after the Superbowl 92 93 and me and
Greg I think had a class would with him
and and I started saying to Brian I was
like young man I was like you want to
buy some Noga beans and he'd be like
would no goo beans and I'm like you know
it's it's drugs man and he's like I
don't do drugs
and we just like okay okay would you
ever want no good beans you just let us
know right so that goes on for maybe
like two weeks and like people around
and we're talking about I'm like just
keep nobody nobody knows about no good
means it's just be it's his big Ladin
and me and Greg and then like I think it
got to a point where at one point like I
was like yo man I was like I still got
those Noga beans and he just like stands
up in the class it goes and then the
teachers like well what is going on here
and kind of like pulls Brian and goes to
talk to him and then the next day at
class like I show up and I have cops
waiting for me and we get pulled into
the office they take us to our lockers
they're like dude I've been like three
cops the principal yeah Dave Allen the
assistant principal Wayne Wiggins
they're like all right there for some
reason I know why Marx Laurette wait
would you get my that morning when you
get to that I'm when I got to that class
I the timing of it i from my
understanding about if I remember
correctly it was like I remember I
walked in a class and then I got called
out immediately the teacher said hey
there wait so many once to him the
principal was talk to you outside and
the principal was standing there with
the cops and then granade Greg - and
Greg is just kind of like like giggly
but like also a little scared white like
he's just like I don't you know we
didn't really know what this was yet and
they take us home and wing Wiggins like
they start digging through my locker
like we haven't no Gabino beans and I
was like I was like no you're you you
you were kidding right he goes
where are the note Bryan Madden says
you've been trying to sell them drugs
they're called Noga beans we've never
heard of them
where are they they fit you guys are
like the [ __ ] I mean you're the tipping
point of some whole news I mean they're
like they're like pushing on the back of
the locker to see if there's like a
false y'all having fentanyl's bad weight
you can hold them no good we did them no
good means you get the strength of five
tonga ripping my [ __ ] apart like you
know a principals their watch and
they're like and I we can they pull us
in basically principal they take us to
the office after that it like starts
where is it and we're like so we make
we're kidding around with them like
these are we made it up it's it's al
Noga beans and they're like the
Washington [ __ ] I'm like yeah and
they're like
yeah I remember I'm in Maine Wiggum just
look at me he goes you dumb [ __ ]
like what is your problem
and then either call my mom they call
both of our parents like my mom finds
out like I get grounded not that big a
deal in the end but it's still like the
idea of just you know cuz this kid went
home he told his parents that someone
was trying to sell him drugs they were
like [ __ ] [ __ ] that I mean I were to
I mean overnight that all happened they
probably like the cops probably like
came to Bryan Bryan gladdens house and
was like it took a report Joey he's a
hick he's next to tell us what they had
and that was my ninth grade year in high
school so so already like run kind of
like a cop show up there's rumors
probably flying everywhere yeah yeah and
then I started hanging out with like
Tasos and Ben and then I actually
started doing drugs like I started
smoking pot on LSD and all that stuff
which was you know I always say this is
just you know when you when you could do
psychedelics without you know the the
knowledge of taxes and credit report
like it's the greatest thing as
possibility yeah but I'm still just this
dude in my high school that like I'm a
little guy you know I mean like I'm like
you know I was probably like five three
five four maybe you know I hadn't really
hit my like growth spurt and so when I
got into tenth grade there wasn't like
no it wasn't death grade it was 11th
grade when I got into 11th grade so my
sisters already out of school it's just
the great above me that's that's pretty
popular and I'm just kind of like
finding my way and so I started taking
it was a class it was the morning
announcements televised morning
announcements right and as your
prerequisite the channel one and this is
funny that I put that on the application
a Marez it was like I did chain I was
like but it didn't it started as just it
was a [ __ ] class that you could take
right and did you get credit for it or
was it extra credit or um
it was a it was a that I would walk in
write it like whatever time in homeroom
and I'm hearing the announcements yeah
it's you up there yeah but then but then
I see I would just I remember what gaint
the footballs Friday and all that it
started with me just doing the voice
announcements we do like to pledge
allegiance and I would work with a
couple other people we change out but I
remember when I started taking the
televised morning announcements because
they had like a makeshift studio like
literally built in the school and like
the big-ass [ __ ] television cameras
and they didn't really put me on air
that often because I was you know I was
a pothead like he's like stoner kid and
with horrible hyperactivity just jacked
up on adderall and finally where it
really really really got cool was that I
was I was in the I was I used I was
behind the camera and they started
adding these little like segments to the
show they had added this thing for this
for this girl to do called music mania
and it was on Fridays and this black
chick was kind of like the host of it
was she talked about if they do all the
could they do all the stuff about the
school and then they cut to her and
she'd be like you know check out that
new Jodeci song it's up riding up the
tracks and don't forget to do this check
out this song and bump a by it was just
it was all BS and in like filler but she
does that for a couple weeks nobody
gives a [ __ ] about it right and then
then one of these than one episode she
goes up there does her whole spiel and
at the end of it she goes she goes and
also I want to give a shout out to all
my brothers going to the Million Man
March this weekend and like she did that
they aired that but then the principal
saw that and principals black too
but he just grows or he's like listen we
can't we can't have that on the morning
announcements it's just that's not part
of the school we have to stalk about
music so they say to her there's like
listen we feel it'd be better just to
take you off of that right and they're
like taking the good through they're
gonna take her off as a host of music
mania and they're like well who else
wants to do it and I didn't recommend I
suppose she says the Million Man March
they were mover not from the class just
from that segment right because I think
you weren't allowed to like do yeah
I don't know I don't know what the rules
argue this is 1994-95 like you know in
America and also I think like the
Million Man March I think also had a bad
connotation to some people because of
Louis Farrakhan and at the time it was
just like a very like touchy subject
especially in a very racially divided
school because Germantown Seneca Valley
I mean dude we had it was just non-stop
fights between like like we white kids
black kids Mexican kids like Maryland
fights Maryland [ __ ] fights dude we
had so many fights in that school so it
was just I could see why something like
that would be like yo we got to cut that
so they're like who's gonna do the music
mania and they're like why don't we have
Josh do it I'm just like all right so
they do the regular like studio shed
they do like you know the regular
announcements and they're like uh we're
gonna cut to Josh Meyers from music
mania and dude I had just taken like a
brand fresh new head of adderall and I
am like a boy what dude I I just go off
and I stick to the script but I riff and
I make fun of like the football team
like not in a bad way making fun of them
but I was like if you guys win this
weekend a blah I just I don't even know
what I said but it was just everybody in
the studio's dying laughing right the
next day that airs in the mornings we
did him the day before god the next day
it airs and I walk out of first period
when they ring the bell a second dude I
am the most popular guy in the school to
the point where they said all right well
we want Josh to do all the morning
announcements now and then he'll do his
music mania every Friday and now you're
doing everything dude I do die I mean I
was like the Jimmy Fallon in the school
just walking about I dude that flag I
was like what's up yeah I mean the most
popular guy in my school that runs for
about I don't know like probably through
that semester and then I don't know
something got cut
just whatever it was but they're like
you're gonna do the final episode and so
I was like killing the final show
everybody's going nuts people are crying
in the studio right and I like as soon
as I'm done like I'd everybody that's my
time I'll see you guys later
and then I lean back and immediately the
teacher comes out and the teachers like
we didn't get any of that
and I'm like novel are you serious cuz I
couldn't even know what I was saying it
was just like stream-of-consciousness
comedic genius like the ghost of Lenny
Bruce came into my body and I just
killed it so like so can you do it again
and I'm like yeah guess so
dude I bombed yeah so [ __ ] hard that
all that fame I had do they turned on me
he was like walking in a hallway the
next day that's pretty bad you I'd study
a little bit harder because I don't
think there's a profession you could be
able to go and do and it was bad
but it is what it is you know and you
know I was still like a so popular guy
at this point too you know because of
the episodes bad or not people love me
that the problem also and I think this
is something that still works for me
today is that regardless of how much
I've changed and how much I've grown
into like a good-looking you know adult
like you still have this this like
baggage that you carry because I was
that I was that wild kid that girls I
remember would be like be like oh you're
really cute on like the first day of
class maybe pass me a note like you know
you know I like you or whatever and then
I started doing my jokes and they'd be
like let's just take that back because I
don't want to date a meth addict and so
high school
you know I was like I said I'm hanging
out with the crunch kids we're smoking
cigarettes were [ __ ] playing music
you know all of them are getting
girlfriends Tasos is dating Lauren
rostec [ __ ] Ben Allen's dating Kim
God sins and it's just like I'm gay
and no attention like no attention at
all and if there is there they're not
telling me let's take a break for our
first sponsor expressvpn so we all know
how expressvpn protects your privacy and
on security online right but here's
something you might not know you can
also use Express VPN to unlock movies
and shows that are only available in
other countries and now that so many of
us are stuck at home it's only a matter
of time until you run out of stuff to
watch on Netflix so this whole week I've
been using expressvpn to binge Doctor
Who on UK Netflix it's so simple to do I
just fire up the expressvpn app I
changed my location to the UK i refresh
Netflix and boom that's it
expressvpn hide your IP address and let
you control where you want sites to
think you're located you can choose from
almost a hundred different countries so
just think about all the Netflix
libraries you can go through if you love
anime expressvpn you get you access to
Japanese Netflix and be spirited away
but it's not just Netflix expressvpn
works with any streaming service it
works with hulu BBC iPlayer YouTube you
name it there are hundreds of VPNs out
there but the reason I use Express VPN
to watch shows is it's ridiculously fast
there's never any buffering or lag and
you can stream an HD no problem
expressvpn is also compatible with all
your devices so your phone's your Media
Console Smart TVs and more you can watch
what you want on a personal device or on
the big screen wherever you are if you
visit my special link right now and
expressvpn dot-com / honey-do you can
get an extra three months of expressvpn
for free that's three months for free
support the show watch what you want and
protect yourself with expressvpn let's
talk about our next sponsor keeps did
you know that two out of three guys will
experience some form of male pattern
baldness by the time they're 35 the best
way to prevent hair loss is to do
something about it while you still have
hair left all right you can get treated
from home with this now you used to have
to go to the doctor's office for your
hair loss prescription but now thanks to
keeps you can visit a doctor online and
get hair loss medication delivered right
to your home they may
easy and deliver your medication every
three months so you can say goodbye to
pharmacy checkout lines and awkward
doctor visits keeps offers generic
versions of the only two fda-approved
hair loss products out there you may
have tried them before but probably
never for this price prevention is the
key keeps treatments can take up to four
to six months or more to see results so
it's important to act fast the sooner
you start using keeps the more hair
you'll save find out why keeps has more
5-star reviews than any of its
competitors and nearly a hundred
thousand men trust keeps for their hair
loss prevention medication keeps
treatments start at just $10 a month
plus for a limited time you can get your
first month for free if you're ready to
take action and prevent hair loss go to
keeps calm / honey-do to receive your
first month of treatment for free
that's ke eps calm / honeydew
let's talk about our next sponsor
stamps.com right now we all need to
avoid crowds any way we can but what if
you need to go to the post office what
if you need post - just send out letters
and packages don't worry
stamps.com is here to help with stamps
calm you can print postage on demand and
skip the lines and crowds at the post
office plus you can actually save some
money with discounts that you can't even
get at the post office and if that
wasn't enough stamps.com also offers UPS
services shoutout to UPS baltimore hub
primary one Joe Avenue with discounts up
to 62 percent and no UPS residential
surcharges stamps.com brings all the
services of the US Postal Service right
to your computer and the safety and
comfort of your own home office or
anywhere else you're hunkering down
right now so whether you're a small
business sending invoices and online
sellers shipping out products or you're
just working from home and need to mail
stuff stamps.com
can handle it all with ease simply use
your computer to print official US
postage 24/7 for any letter any packages
any class of mail anywhere you want to
send and like I said with stamps com get
great discounts - five cents off every
first-class stamp and up to 62 percent
off shipping rates right now my
listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in honey-do that stamps.com
enter honey-do stay safe my friends now
let's get back to the do so we get into
our senior year right you know and at
this point I've hooked up when I went to
camp when I went to summer camp when I
was younger you know my first kiss was
Kim LaRocca the next year going into
eighth grade I got a load I got a blow
job for the first time at summer camp
probably way too young probably ruined
re8 going into eighth grade probably
ruined me that's also one of the
weirdest things I've ever experienced my
life because we had we're haven't yet
tell me how how did you pull it off so
my girl
sorry so first of all right so it was
going into sixth grade I don't hear name
going to 6th grade a kiss Kim for the
first time so we'd have two weeks of
summer camp and on the last two days
we'd have an overnight there's that
Seneca Creek State Park right mmm in
Germantown and dude those overnights man
you know as kids we bring our parents
would stalk us up with candy some Jolt
Cola so we just get [ __ ] jacked up
dude on sugar and I was already kind of
like dating means sixth grade dating Kim
and I remember we kissed for the first
time in the 10th and I just remember it
was just both of our mouths just open
fuller huh like no tongue no nothing
just moving that around then the next
year I hooked up with this chick Noelle
who was in an older session group than I
was she was like integrate above me and
all the guys wanted to write but she
liked me and I remember we're on the bus
and and everybody's like so you're gonna
French kiss Noelle today and I'm like
all right yeah like rubbing my shoulders
gimme some of that bug juice give me
some of that bug juice and I remember
we're in the back of the bus and every
time they're like couldn t like kibosh
come on it's like a grip of people
around me and I'm just
alright [ __ ] it start the timer 14
seconds and then you just start we start
making out that overnight that year I
touch boobs for the first time for Noel
and it was you know the most magical
experience of your life as a young kid
also which made it even doper was in the
background the music playing was the new
jack city soundtrack because I had Color
Me badd I want to sex you up on it but
then like the song would change and it
would be like no Jack knew Jack knew
Jack hustla I'm just tickling titties
cuz I didn't know what I was doing so
then the next year going into eighth
grade I remember I didn't have a
girlfriend all semester and would cause
semester session and the morning of the
overnight we all show up and this chick
Jen was dating some other guy and then
it came out I think the night before on
the ride home the day before the campout
she broke up with the dude this is not a
sleepover cam this no wasn't it was it
was it was almost - it was a it was
probably 12 full days of daytime
sessions you know 8:00 a.m. until 3:00
p.m. and then on the last Thursday and
Friday you'd have an overnight so we'd
show up at 3:00 p.m. and they they cook
a steak UM's we play like games like you
know dude it was it was honestly just
you know thing I haven't thought about
this in years like I could just remember
the joy in the excitement it's like
because anything was possible you know
what it reminded me of it was like it
was like you remember how dope it felt
to go to Ocean City Maryland when you
were a teenager yeah well anything was
possible
girls were there the cool rock band
t-shirts that you couldn't find anywhere
were sold there like it was just you
know just white trash people walking
around just you want to get a water ice
and you're like yeah so camp had that
that same feeling and so it was so she
breaks up with the dude the day before I
show up at 3 p.m. and somebody comes up
to her one of her like underlings and
they're like I just let you know you
know she no Jen broke up with that guy
she likes yeah and then we run off so
next thing I know two hours later that's
my girlfriend
ya know because that's the way it is she
agreed in a relation relationship within
15 minutes and I remember like I
remember there was kind of an incident
because it rained a little bit so we had
to watch a movie before we went up to
the hill we were watching my girl you
know am i right watching my girl and and
then she says to me like she just says
to me like you know I really like you I
remember standing up on the chair in
front of everybody being like she likes
me everybody
she likes me we go up that hill and I
remember we have a little section cuz it
was me and Jen and then Chris Sal Pino
and his girlfriend and [ __ ] said
everyone ok I know Chris is gone he
unfortunately passed away Big Ups
resident sappy you know but but I
remember he's in he's in his sleeping
bag with his girl and I get in my
sleeping bag with my girl and and Chris
it's just like just moving around a lot
he goes he goes because josh I'm
fingering and I'm just like telling me
I'm like really any was like I was like
a look at a girl go
can I think of you she's like yeah go
ahead and so then I go to in there to do
it and Chris up you know I remember I
always say it's he goes just heads up
the holes lower than you think it's
gonna be best advice I ever got my life
I still to this day I always go a little
bit low it's a P no new so you so then
so then she so then we do that to keep
this in mind I'm going to eighth grade
and then we go into a 10 and then just
she gives me a [ __ ] and then the next
day it she's in ninth or C's no no she's
going in C same grade as manga but just
then you know summers the season ends
and I go back to school and I'm just
regular funny guy Josh cuz they see me
all the time you know what I mean
they've known me for years they known
the stupid [ __ ] that I've done so I
wasn't getting that kind of play in high
school
so senior year we had this one girl that
went there named Tammy right Tammy was
so cute you know she was just cute like
she was I didn't realize she was a raver
already at 16 because she was wearing
the outfits
that I came to find that out later that
that she was but she was just she look
like Bjork little balls on her hair and
she was she was also already sexually
active like I remember she was hooking
up with some some pretty [ __ ] older
guys in the school like Aiden and and
some of the bigger black guys that were
like very popular at our school played
football and stuff and so she starts
dating my friend Jesse and we say hang
out in Jesse's basement and smoke smoke
weed and and take like mushrooms and
stuff and I just like hit it off with
her and then me and her had this art
class right and it was a murder the
professor would professor teacher was
guy mr. Moran who literally looks like
soar named mister looks like he might as
well be Moran Nash and young you know
what I mean it looks like every 70s
California rocker big beard and
everybody would skip class and go hang
out in his class because it was just the
cool art class and also we had something
on him because my friend Tay and cavae
were searching through jackets I guess
to steal [ __ ] and they went into some
jacket and they found a bag of pot right
and they kept it and then the next day
mr. Moran pulled him aside and was like
it was like hey did you guys go into my
jacket and grab something so they
admitted it to the COS he he knew he
knew we talked about all that [ __ ] he
was just a cool teacher so he would let
everybody hang out there and so me and
Tammy would like hang out and so we
would go back to my house after that
we'd skip class and just like she
literally gave me every opportunity to
have sex with this girl and I just
[ __ ] I was just too scared you know I
was too scared to make a move now we're
gonna pause the Tammy thing for a moment
and then we're gonna pull up Michelle
Gilliam Michelle Gilly I can't look I'll
say her name because I'm gonna do is
talk really nice about this girl this is
still to this day the most beautiful
girl sexiest girl I've ever seen in my
life she was just like remember she was
in the grade above me but she wore like
the cool
rock t-shirts you know she the cool
earrings you know a great body for you
know nine tenth grade you know and all
your hormones are going crazy plus in
our yearbook I don't know if they did it
on purpose but there was a picture of
her like like looking into legis they
got microscope or like a stethoscope
whatever the [ __ ] to called and like
she's looking at a stethoscope she's
looking into it and it's like her shirts
kind of low-cut and literally in our
yearbook still have it her titties just
like hanging out come on
swear to god dude I still jerk off to
Michelle if you listen girl Michelle
your parents should have flag they're
[ __ ] here votes there the principal
was like let's keep that photo in there
you know we can't put that into the
timepiece we put in the green the times
day it was dude it was she was the
hottest girl I remember she left she got
in some trouble
tom cassell yeah I remember she'd gotten
into trouble and next thing I know she
moves to my neighborhood right and you
know I'm like she's a pothead I'm a
pothead we like the same music and I had
heard that she had hooked up with a guy
that was not one of the cool guys just a
regular dude I remember his name just
regular dude and I was like well I mean
[ __ ] if if he can get her I mean I think
I could have a chance too but it just
started it because she live in the
neighborhood we just started this little
friendship where we would just walk
around we'd go to each other's like like
houses and like to our rooms listen to
music smoke pot and you know we'd go
down to mr. Moran's like we hang out
there it was just like we weren't dating
but it was like there was a real
friendship there this moment I'm about
to tell you right now is the most
honey-do moment of my life because this
is the baggage that I carry with me
forever
we're in my room after school my parents
are downstairs
we're chillin we're listening to the
Beatles she's sitting on my bed gorgeous
and she's like Josh why haven't you
tried to kiss me or like hook up
me or anything and me being the funny
guy goes because and I say this in the
most sarcastic way but I'm like because
we're such good friends Michelle I would
hate to ruin that she goes oh stands up
takes her sweater off just her bra big I
mean perfect the most perfect breasts
I've ever seen in my life she walks
right up to me
leans down into my ear and she goes I
wanna [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of you and I'm
just like but she go and then she looks
at me I don't say anything I'm just and
she goes all right I gotta get out of
here I'll see you later and then she
left
oh dude and I mean dude I had her
moments in my life wait that would have
been your virginity that would have been
my virginity right there with the girl
of my dreams but not even that not even
that right it would have been I took
initiative I [ __ ] I manned up in a
moment and was like no I was like being
confident oh yeah she did she split
giggles dude I think about that that is
that is still you dude there's got it I
still like gotta be bringing that [ __ ]
up in therapy and just remembering that
and the worst part was she disappeared
after that because she went to a
different school because I think she had
gotten in trouble or something I don't
want to add another story because I
don't know it but she was just gone
I did run into her years later I ran
into her at a rave [ __ ] like she was
all goth doubt and she was sexy and I
remember I was all [ __ ] up on coke and
like we talked and there was like a
moment there you know but the Tammy
thing comes back around because we're
still hanging out during this time and
then because I hadn't lost my virginity
and everybody assumed that I had lost my
virginity I just lied and said we had
had sex she never denied it she I don't
have anybody ever asked her about it but
like it was like that was what everybody
thought
I lost my virginity - but it took until
I think you know many more years not
many more maybe like a year and a half
after my senior year not even I think I
was 18 when when it happened I remember
virginity when I lost my virginity you
got a [ __ ] at what like 12 12 13 I
say 13 I was a little younger so
probably 12 I was always like a year
younger like I'm a late birthday so I'm
in November meat scorpions just I just
saw deer at a young age no dude it was
all there there were so many
opportunities this in my life where I
could have like hooked up with some of
these girls man like dude I don't know
one time there was a girl at my house I
took her out to dinner
this girl was was literally hanging out
in my parents basement until 3:00 4:00
in the morning now at this point I'm
told I'm 19 years old right and I take
her on the date she's hanging out I mean
it's way past the date she's sitting
there waiting for me to hook up with her
if anything that did happen that ruined
it was that we went to this place called
cafe miletto right in Germantown and I
had the chicken marsala
I had a tiramisu we'd go back to the
house we started watching her lights in
a movie she's sitting on one part of the
couch I'm sitting on the other and I'm
just like oh [ __ ] I got a sneeze and as
I go to sneeze I fought and I mean loud
so it's like yeah just simultaneous at
the same time fart and sneeze and I go
oh my god I'm so sorry she goes what god
bless you and it was like oh she didn't
hear it but she sure as [ __ ] smelled it
should dried up her buzzy so quick let's
have more sour so
[Laughter]
see love does he leave I mean ya know
it's so bad you know it was like you
know listener I eat clean now my farts
probably have a little tang to him but
they're not as bad I mean this is like
I'm putting ecstasy in me and ketamine
and all these [ __ ] other Donald
drinking McDonald's you know you're 19
years old you eat like garbage so so
finally I'm out of high school now
because that happened a few years later
and I still then had sex and me Greg I
didn't know that you didn't lose your
virginity until after it was my it was
my first year of Mercy or Pio and the
way to calendar works should have been
but I'm a late birth I mean mercury was
in retrograde so you know I can't deal
with it my crystals weren't clean so so
we have this so we you know I had hooked
up but there just wasn't sex it was
making out and then but also like I
would make out with a girl and then I
just didn't have any tact or class also
all the drugs are on your dick even work
and then or is it just coke dick and
it's way to go I'd know but by the time
by that would be the time with a fart
girl that by that time I had already had
sex that was just I could just name 40
other times I could add a girl like
waiting for me to hook up I still think
that's a problem that a lot of the fans
a lot of people I listen to me last year
I had a girl who I'm still friends with
that I met out here but 20 years ago
married now whatever and everybody had
got together one night drinking and she
just said I just have to ask you how
come you never made a move on me and I
was like huh I was like I had a shot and
man yeah who didn't know I had that I
can't had so many times now most of the
time like I have sealed the deal but I
mean there's like like five six seven
eight times that I can personally
remember that was like we went on a date
didn't try I didn't make a move because
I just was like either too afraid and or
not confident enough of myself that
night so I graduated high school in 97
it's April of 98
me and my friends decide to go to Myrtle
Beach right me Greg dead cat this got
Brian Mao and we're going to meet our
friend who lives in North Carolina named
Jiwon right Chauhan's are two homey he
moved down there maybe a couple years
prior and we were all like super tight
so we were excited and at this point now
like I've inherited the money so I had
like all the [ __ ] dope no you should
please that yes I was
dude I had because I went out and I
bought two thousand dollars worth of
fleece that one night I mean dude it was
it was a holiday season I was buying
gifts for people I had just gotten the
the 30,000 well 40,000 gave 22 my
parents kept 20 and it was just like I
never had money so I'm just buying
people [ __ ] so I never had clothes so I
was like well fleeces are in so I'm
gonna buy all the hot ones
Nautica Tommy Hilfiger you know and I
just that was my [ __ ] and I remember so
where's we're going to to Myrtle Beach
this is like I got my like hip Imbros on
you know what I mean I've got like my
adidas like chanclas just you you feel
like you know you've got highlights in
your hair maybe it's you know it's a
late 90s and so we go there and on the
first night like I don't know how it
happens but suddenly we've got a couple
girls in the room and Greg and
Seidenberg
they both had girlfriends so they're
like nah they're like they're just
[ __ ] like I told you that we like to
[ __ ] around
so like T's and people you know just
being kind of like [ __ ] but in like
a fun flirty kind of way to kind of help
get me and I think g'wan laid well next
thing I know like this girl's like
really thrown it at me she's cute she
was like short blonde hair
you know not not ugly at all or anything
I don't I don't you know but I don't
remember this girl's name and next thing
I know it's just me and her in the hotel
room and this is it do you know what I
mean you feel it like you know it like
like I'm
rock-hard probably's her first time
don't know I don't think so and that'll
come after that because so we start we
start making house it I'm gonna need on
[Laughter]
the 200 I'll do half and half she I just
remember we're making out clothes are
coming off one at a time you know and
then I think the question do you have a
condom and you're just like freaking out
so I ran to get one before I've already
to put it on she's laying there naked
and I'm just like I was like here wait
here for a second and I run to the
icebox right and I grab a couple Ice
Cube's because I had only seen sex in
like porno and nine and a half weeks so
I started like like put it on her
nipples and then I started doing it on
her vagina and she's like riding them
around but it's just like what is the
the thought process in my head that is
like I don't know this girl's name like
I don't [ __ ] have any idea who this
chick is never gonna see her again I'm
gonna get but I just want to I just want
to give her ultimate pleasure freeze or
clitoris we're 22 degrees can I go in
sixteen on your [ __ ] dude I did I did
like three Ice Cube's like I didn't used
to do one this is your I know you've had
sexual encounters but this is the first
time we're having sex ed this is your
foreplay only baby ultimate bad you got
usually people listen to you could you
have you get down with Josh ultimate
pleasure you better know your old ass
bite on your [ __ ]
haven't you done [ __ ] like that before
yeah but not the first like I listen my
first time I was 15 years old she was
I'm a Pisces
[Laughter]
Blood Moon but we were in the back we
parked at this old soccer field it was
like oh it was like a Friday night or
something like that
we drove her dad Chevy Trailblazer she
was a virgin I was a virgin we put the
seats down laid blankets in the back and
it was terrible I mean we both wrenching
away and then you know it lasted just a
few minutes and then it was over and
then we went back to her house and
watched a movie and she would wanted to
talk about it like she both of us hadn't
couldn't believe we had just had like oh
my god that's we just did that that was
it yeah it wasn't I mean I didn't have
[ __ ] ice cubes and she dared it here
I remember this because I remember I
didn't I don't think I felt a nice cube
might have been on the way America
smalls warning that a clutch so we do
our thing I remember how long it lasts I
just remember I didn't finish like I
think I was too nervous we're just a
condom you know what I mean like I don't
think it's to see how you can come in a
condom I mean even now it's like you
know horrible but that being said we do
it and I remember it's actually funny
because literally the next day I had so
much confidence and I remember we go to
we go like we're gonna go to like a bar
like a nightclub and Greg and scene Berg
didn't go but I was like nah dude I was
like I'm going I'm gonna try to get laid
again and [ __ ] Brian goes with me and
since I'm underage and Brian's of age
Brian would go buy beers and then like
hand them to me
and I couldn't because you're dancing
but you still you have to like kill it
as fast as you can I'm still like I'm
like 120 pounds of the most i probably
face like eight nine beers the next
thing you know a blackout and I wake up
in jail in Myrtle Beach jail just a
video we yeah there's a video I've
posted on my social media you can see me
being released from prison from what I
told what I found Heil prison
take it up a notch there's a holding
cell it was a cage I mean they just
touch my way no it was well what I
thought I happened was that like Brian
will give me two beers and then I
started dancing with this like really
really not good-looking girl I started
making out with her took my shirt off
and then I went and hid sat in a booth
and made out with her I fell asleep
making out with her security sees me
asleep try to wake me up I won't wake up
they poked me I say something to him
because Brian told me all this [ __ ] I
say like [ __ ] you
they grab me use my head to open the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] big-ass doors throw
me into some trash which the cops happen
to be standing by they [ __ ] arrest me
take me the drunk tank I remember
sobering up as I get to the drunk tank
and I had never been to jail before so I
was like oh I'm this funny guy so I'm
just gonna try to make people laugh dude
I started doing like they're morning
announcements like my it was it was it
was music mania yeah it was music mania
and I'm like shucking and jiving I'm
making fun of people I'm just like and
this it's packed and I started talking
about being Jewish and suddenly as soon
as I'm done I go to sit down these two
Jewish twins in matching purple shirts
always remember this walk up to me and
then [ __ ] like throw me against the
wall like you started choking me like
Latrell Sprewell and they're like you
[ __ ]
don't you [ __ ] ever talk [ __ ] about
Jewish people they're like do you
understand how hard we've worked to get
to the blah blah blah and they're just
like they're really two of you or modest
survivors [ __ ] yeah and then they they
this I get released you know tell them
you're Jewish
oh yeah maybe they don't not give a [ __ ]
and then as I'm getting release and my
buddy Greg is like signing me out 6:00
in the morning they get released as well
and I'm just like I remember I told Greg
I was like see it
[Laughter]
[Music]
put your goddamn yarmulke on put your
yarmulke put it all straight but yes so
that was it and then funnily from that
you know if you want to watch the video
of me being released it's it's one of
those moments like a video that I am so
happy it exists I mean like how many
people can say that they have it cuz
it's funny it's not like it's not like
they're covering me and I'm like ah
because I got when I got released
I had no flip flops no shirt no wallet
no keys no nothing just on a pair of up
bras that was it I'm brave ready and
brave and that was how I lost my
virginity and then after that years
later I was at a rave and it's funny
because the whole Tammie mustard thing I
run into her there we start flirting one
thing led to another
circle back alright do you the greatest
the greatest circle back of my life in
middle school there was a girl I asked
out every week every single week his
girl Heather I asked her out every
single snake is doctor now under her
house and started stalking is is like
stalking I passed a note hey I like you
you want to go out with me every week
no every single time you want to talk
about that baggage that honey do [ __ ]
that you got that's it right there
that's the [ __ ] that cuz you're you're
in eighth grade when you do it the first
time then you do it again in ninth grade
you try it again in tenth grade and just
just no no no no no rejection man it's
the worst so I mean I held onto that
pain for a long time and then I'm on my
20th birthday
my buddy it was like the manager of this
clothing store called mr. rags takes me
into a rave in Baltimore after this
point cuz I wrecked my car I got him I
got my first DUI so I was like he was
like right around that first birthday
after that where I was like you know a
mess in a sense of like I wasn't going
out as much so he's taking me out for my
20th birthday and we go to this rave in
Baltimore guess who's there
Heather
she's with her boyfriend though but
she's ignoring her boyfriend to hang out
with me by the end of that night
I mean she's throwing herself at me by
the end of that night I had sex with her
I don't think I've ever felt better to
be able to drop that baggage it's the
greatest birthday gift I've ever got the
only thing that could have been better
is if Cal Ripkin me however if you would
have walked in with the enemy like oh
yeah there's another story you wanted to
tell me about Lollapalooza and I want to
hear this one okay then we got to get
you out of here all right
so this do you did you ever go to the
Lollapalooza as when it was traveling
yes so I went when I first moved to
California was 94 and that was when Kurt
Cobain died and I'd already had tickets
when I was going back home for the
summer yeah so I went to a ton of
concerts I saw Pink Floyd at the Rose
Bowl here that year then went back and
saw him at RFK summer Lollapalooza was
the same summer and when Kurt Cobain
died the Smashing Pumpkins stepped in
and headlined and oh I mean I'm not not
[ __ ] on Smashing Pumpkins because
they're right but it's like it's not
Nirvana it's like but we got God I think
I want to say The Beastie Boys were
there I think A Tribe Called Quest like
l7o breeders in breeders Raider yeah my
sister went to that I didn't Charles Tom
West Virginia that's the one I went to I
didn't I didn't go to that one but I
this was when this whole town this was
when this is when Lollapalooza started
wasn't just you it was it was like it
was another touring like Lollapalooza
but it was always the same lineup I
don't know if you remember it like it
was warped or something like like that
yeah it was that it was that Nissan
Pavillion in Virginia now the Jiffy Lube
Center or whatever the [ __ ] it's called
and it was dude I mean you talk about a
dope like early 2000s lineup it was
Jane's Addiction Audioslave Queens of
the Stone Age Incubus the Donna's I'm
missing but there was something there
were some other cool bands too and I
remember I rode there with with not
friends that I had tickets with but
other friends it we were gonna go my
actually it was my friend my
Jenny who lives out here now I think
sure and her sister were going and I
hopped a ride so I can meet my buddies
and on the car ride there you know we
leave early cuz it's a festival you know
this is like you know I'm really
drinking I'm doing drugs this is still
early it's like 2002 2003 and I and on
the ride there I start drinking Road
beers right dude it's we're sitting in
traffic so I probably drink ten
realistically we show up and I run into
all my homies and one of my homies Matt
had some like vicodin and he was like
hand in the mouth because you know you
shouldn't mix booze and painkillers but
if you take it just to right it feels
good and you know we were like we're
going to see some of our favorite bands
so let's get [ __ ] up so I pop six of
them and so i pop six cuz that's good
i'm names i know [ __ ] ain't no [ __ ]
yeah and i'm going to see Audioslave for
the first time so excited and we're
drinking and then the next thing you
know i'm talking everybody who's girls
around us [ __ ] we're having the best
time and i just got you know my
breakfast part and i go to lift my cheek
over to the side huh no immediately I'm
like oh no dude
oh no and dude there's hot and [ __ ] all
day festival this is summertime I'm like
I'm like I was like here's about the
biasing style t-shirt to wipe my ass
well here's what I thought I was like
alright I'm just gonna grab some like
paper towels or something and go there's
some like foliage out in the background
some trees and [ __ ] I'm gonna go back
there into the cut and just clean myself
and then rejoin the group but couldn't
find any paper towels so I'm in I'm in
the foliage I've take my pants off
I had brand-new white Ralph Lauren
boxers was it like $18.00 a pair
brand-new first time wearing them I have
to wipe my own ass with boxy
now nobody saw me yeah
yet because then eventually Matt sees
because using with Josh banner where are
you where are you hard because it's not
there's cars all over here yeah and then
there's like a divider between more cars
but it's just grass and like a little
dip but it's like bushes and a couple
trees like I'm in the thick of that but
little did I know that you could see my
face clear uluru I'm covered but you can
just see me like going and that's like
the [ __ ] you doing Josh was like there's
like nothing he's like you [ __ ] yourself
and I'm like no and I just throw the
underwear meet my way back start
pounding beers
I feel clean enough so we get into the
concert and we don't even started
nothing head in the morning probably
dude and I'm already a [ __ ] mess and
we get into the concert holes in one
ship and and I remember my buddy Scotty
was like had been dating this this girl
I don't dating he's hooking up with this
girl because we get beers the second
weekend in there man and I just I just
remember it's like I don't remember
everything I just remember flashes of
what happened I remember one the girl
that Scotty was [ __ ] attacking me
just in a line like I remember we're
waiting for lining I see to argue with
me and I start arguing with her about
whatever it is and she rushes me and
then Scotty who's a big dude like
literally like clotheslines are not like
just trying to hold her back
she runs so fast and he's puts his arm
out it was huge like thick arms and just
knocks her down and he's like Josh you
need to get the [ __ ] out of here and I'm
just like [ __ ] this [ __ ] man I don't
need this [ __ ] and I'm just drunk acting
a scene and then knocks in the prison
[Laughter]
prison little Pelican Bay all day
23-hour lockdown I know I know that bad
that part moves on all I remember is I
don't know what I do
if I try to steal beers or I try to
steal a t-shirt or some or all the
probably all of the above I remember
security grabbing me and just walking me
out and me being like [ __ ] you guys you
[ __ ] I paid for this decade [ __ ] you
I didn't do anything wrong and they
throw me out and I keep trying to get
back in and they're just like they're
don't they're like dude if you don't
leave we're gonna call the police
so my [ __ ] you guys so I keep walking I
see that behind all this foliage there's
this I go to the other side of the venue
there's this high ass fence dude like
how high dude 20 30 feet
bakit as I say yards remember looking up
at it I mean like I can do that and dude
I just I [ __ ] scale this fence I get
to the top I start trying to come down
and I remember just falling landing on
my back you fell the whole way back I'm
laying laying on the ground I think I
knocked myself out like I just wake up
I'm just like oh [ __ ] I heard like
Audioslave playing I mean Orion I was in
I run through I am covered in dirt and
[ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ] and I get to the
pavilion point not the pavilion in the
field part like he's in the field part
and I run into all my buddies Joel and
[ __ ] Paul all the dudes and they're
they look at me and I mean I've got like
Tom Hanks in castaway you know what I
mean about closer ripped it obviously I
made it back in man I made it back in
and I remember I remember the car ride
home nobody wanted to sit next to me cuz
I smelled like [ __ ] that story had a
happy ending oh it's the same [ __ ] I say
every time I do this I love that I could
take these stories that have that have
held me back in so many ways and to tell
them on the honeydew and the crab feast
and the 500 it's it's like you're taking
these negatives and making them a
positive like what you're doing with
this podcast
something that the crab fees could never
do which is like actually there's you're
helping people because a lot of these
people yeah I bet you there's you've got
I got a hundred fans that [ __ ] themself
at Lollapalooza
I got [ __ ] myself at Lilith Fair well
thank you for saying that
my pleasure dude I love that I'm happy
to be doing the show I love doing the
show and I love having you on please
again plug everything you want your
social media the podcasts all that
alright at Josh a demeyers on all social
media the podcast is the 500 with Josh
Adam Meyers on Spotify join the movement
and check out it comes out June 12th so
probably when this comes out or whatever
check out the new season of f is for
family on Netflix I play DJ howl and
Hank it's a great show and I love you
dude thank you for having me on this
this was like the best way to celebrate
a day during quarantine is just to kick
it with you and talk about my shows that
up yeah yeah and thank you all as well I
am Ryan Sickler on all social media make
sure you subscribe to the YouTube
channel it will be a link in the episode
description here at the end of the show
and we'll talk to you all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]